[Musique]
depuis un an des travaux de suppression
du radier de la ravine blanche ont
débuté situé sur la route départementale
400 qui est la limite entre la commune
de saint pierre est celle du tampon cet
ouvrage assure en priorité la sécurité
des usagers
le département a entamé une campagne de
six nations
des radiers de cette routine à cinq au
total et celui de la ravine blanche et
le premier c'est le premier ouvrage que
nous faisons pour pouvoir franchir la
rabine même partant de plus l'utilité et
la sécurité des usagers de la route
départementale voitures camions qui est
ton vélo tous les usagers pourront
traverser
entendu en temps depuis le radier sans
danger dimensionnement a été fait avec
une crue centennale
donc effectivement
[Musique]
un projet de 2 millions d'euros
entièrement financés par le département
il fait partie d'une opération de
suppression de 5 radiers sur ses pattes
un autre ouvrage là qui est à l'appel
d'offres donc on va certainement
démarrer les travaux débutent 2021 c'est
sur le bras d'antoine
environ un kilomètre en kilomètre et
demi il ya trois autres
radié aussi à supprimer ravine dangereux
radwan famine des cabris alors
suite à la crise et aux kobe 19 le
chantier a pris du retard ouvrages
devraient être livrés au plus tard au
mois de septembre
[Musique]